lacks a sense of purpose in his new book
returned to greatness this talk is just
over an hour that unfair is a good segue
into Alan Wolf's new book because he is
considering the questions of equity and
he we're very happy to welcome back Alan
wolf as some of you know he's the
director of the how do you say boys I
Wasi Wasi Center for Religion and Public
Life at Boston College and you were here
two years ago were you know for a book
about considering the changes in
religious life in in in the United
States with the inclusion of people of
many different of faiths from the
traditional ones the Christian and
Judaic faiths so tonight's book is
called a return to greatness and the
book was written professor wolf was
inspired by the events of 2001 and also
by the election in 2004 he is arguing
that achieving national greatness
involves three tasks articulating a
vision of American purpose creating a
political strategy to transform that
vision into reality and a willingness to
use force if necessary
to protect that vision from attack he
distinguishes between goodness and
greatness and he urges our nation to
return to an activist model of greatness
so this is a very pertinent book for
many of us and I know that you'll be
well rewarded by hearing professor Alan
wolf speak tonight
well thanks so much for the introduction
and for the summary of the book I came
out that question isn't it the caller
was right that the book was inspired by
the 2004 election and the events of 2001
but even more than that
it really had its origins in the
original election that brought our
current president to power the famous
election of 2000 famous for its hanging
chads and it's Supreme Court deciding to
repudiate all its previous precedents
and decide the election on fairly
partisan grounds and all of those other
things that kept people up wondering
what had happened to their country for
month after month actually my interest
in that election was not only the fact
that it brought us mr. Bush as president
I think there's something really
fascinating happened in 2000 that
happened long before any Chad decided to
hang from any ballot and the real
inspiration in my book is not why did
the Supreme Court decide that election
in favor of one candidate rather than
another and it's not in why did the
person who got the higher majority vote
Al Gore not become president it's the
question of how did Al Gore and George W
Bush come to run against each other in
the first place because as some of you
no doubt remember they weren't the only
two candidates for president in that
year each had a significant opponent in
his own primary in his own political
party
Al Gore ran against Bill Bradley the
former senator from New Jersey and
George W Bush ran against John McCain
the current senator from Arizona and so
I think actually the really fascinating
question is why didn't Bill Bradley run
against John McCain for president of the
United States in 2000 that's actually a
very very interesting question to ask
because at another period in American
history my guess is that that would have
they would have been the two people
chosen to run in their party the
Democratic Party after all has been a
party that for approximately a hundred
years that nearly all of its great
political leader
have come from the northeastern part of
the United States including Bradley's
own adopted state New Jersey which
produced one of the great Democratic
presidents of the of the 20th century
Woodrow Wilson and really one of the
most interesting stories about American
politics is how did it come to pass that
no person from the Northeast or from New
England in the Democratic Party can be
elected president of the United States
in in Bradley's case because he didn't
win the nomination a southerner named Al
Gore won the nomination which also kind
of raises the question of why is it that
the only Democrats that can become
elected president of the United States
are people from the south such as Bill
Clinton Jimmy Carter and if you believe
he won in 2000 Al Gore as well so that
that in itself is a fascinating question
what happened to the New England
northeastern leadership class in the
United States that class that produced
Woodrow Wilson and Franklin Delano
Roosevelt and John F Kennedy all
presidents that aspired in one way or
another to the idea of American
greatness how did it become possible
that that group of people is no longer
capable of electing one of their own as
president and of course the other
interesting question is why didn't John
McCain get the Republican nomination he
seemed to be far more experienced than
his opponent he's a man who had been a
senator for some time he was a war hero
his opponent didn't manage to finish a
term in the National Guard McCain was
widely acknowledged as a man of
experience and integrity you may not
have liked his views but he really
seemed to embody the spirit of former
presidents in the Republican party such
as Theodore Roosevelt in fact he seemed
to be almost a a walking replica of
Theodore Roosevelt having gone through
the same experience with the Navy and
having translated a courageous an
honorable military career into a
successful position as a political
leader just as Theodore Roosevelt had
done and yet despite all of those
impressive credentials the Republican
Party chose to nominate instead a
one-term governor of Texas who was known
generally for not knowing much about the
world for
being something of a lazy unaccomplished
person and a fascinating question what
had happened to the Republican Party
that made it in a position where it
would prefer as its presidential
candidate someone like George W Bush a
Texan or although of course originally
from Connecticut rather than from
someone that seemed to aspire to the
Roosevelt II and mantle so you could see
where I'm heading I I think that my book
in a sense tries to explain what
happened to both our political parties
what happened to both our political
ideologies liberalism and conservatism
that produced a situation in which
without you know I don't know whether
Bill Bradley or John McCain would have
made great presidents but I think it's
fair to say that our political parties
are not necessarily interested in
nominating for president people of
experience and vision who come from the
historically traditional locations that
have produced our leaders in the past
when I look back on American history I
see a number of great leaders and a
number of great presidents and as you've
already heard what I try to do in the
book is to crystallize what the idea of
greatness has meant in American history
I break it down into three component
parts the first is the idea that America
must stand for something something
important in American political culture
the two great objectives for which this
country has stood are the ideals of
liberty and equality and those are
wonderful ideas and magnificent ideas
standing for them articulating them
articulating what they mean Abraham
Lincoln's for example magnificently
defined equality in the Gettysburg
Address and in other of his speeches
having some sense some real sense of
what liberty and equality mean is an
important aspect of holding up an ideal
that America can aspire to but I think a
second thing is much more important
because anyone can use good rhetoric if
they have a good speechwriter that's
kind of all you need
it's much much more although it's
amazing how bad American speech writers
are but that's another question for
another book and another evening the
really important thing is developing
some way of realizing to some degree of
the ideals of liberty and equality in
the United States some developing some
mechanism for translating that into
reality and as I argue in my book
crucial to that crucial to the notion
that liberty and equality have actual
real meaning are things like the idea of
national citizenship the idea that we
are all citizens of one nation and that
everyone should have the basic rights
and liberties of citizenship and that
everyone should be able to express these
rights it is a to me and I hope it would
be to you as well
that if we define the fundamental equal
rights of citizenship as the ideal that
defines the American nation then I argue
in the book that America did not become
a nation until 1965 with the passage of
the Voting Rights Act one of the most
important pieces of legislation which
for the first time in our history
guaranteed the notion that people would
have the right to vote that they would
not be prevented from owning on the
basis of such arbitrary characteristics
as their skin going it took us two
hundred years from our founding to
actually embody the principle of equal
national citizenship it's a vote it's a
hard and difficult thing to do to create
a nation and in this country there have
always been forces that have opposed the
idea of national citizenship in part
because the National citizenship means
the notion of exercising and having
centralized political authority
political authority in the form of an
efficient government that can actually
carry out the people's will and as I
think it's obvious from our present era
this is not a country that believes in
government at least it people frequently
expressed their skepticism toward
government the idea of government as
embodying the actual material resources
for bringing about equality and liberty
through the idea of national citizenship
has always been a very very different
thing to achieve but it seems to me to
be central no country can be great until
its people are great no country can be
strong if its people are weak a strong
country a great country utilizes the
resources of every person and if
providing social security or providing
health insurance or providing protection
against capricious and arbitrary
employers is a way of utilizing the
potential of every person then those
things have to go into the meaning of
American greatness and then thirdly if
liberty and equality are important and
realizable ideals at home they ought to
be internationally as well I think
standing for American greatness also
means standing for the notion that
America has obligations in the world
that when people in the world believe
and try to take their own ideals of
liberty and equality into their own
hands that we should be there to help
them that we should be there to
strengthen liberty and equality to the
best of our abilities I think our
primary obligations are to American
citizens first but we also have
obligations internationally and if we're
going to be a great country we need to
take those seriously as well now having
said all those three things you know at
the level of language who's opposed to
greatness I mean everyone every
president they all talk about how great
we are the notion of greatness is just
sort of automatically thrown about well
what I hope to persuade you is that
greatness is so difficult to achieve
that it's really been the exception
throughout American history rather than
the rule because the things that it
carries with it are very very demanding
it carries with it a sense of obligation
a sense of duty a sense of sacrifice a
sensible willingness to pay for these
things these are not things that come
free they just don't occur in nature and
are there for the plucking these are
hard and difficult things to achieve and
we haven't always achieved them in their
history and we haven't always achieved
them because there has been throughout
our history another idea or ideal about
what America should be that has been in
sharp competition with the idea of
American greatness and I call it in my
book
the idea of American goodness that we
are torn between a conception of
greatness and a conception of goodness
goodness implies that the United States
has been blessed by God to do special
things in the world that we are a chosen
people that we've been chosen to be
virtuous to demonstrate to the rest of
the world
the necessity of
overcoming sin of living lives of virtue
of being a city on a hill shining beacon
to people throughout the world I mean
the language is one that is as familiar
as apple pie in this country because
it's been used so often throughout our
history goodness
does not merely imply the same kinds of
things that greatness does the notion of
American goodness has its origins really
in the American Revolution and in the
rebellion against Europe and for so many
of our early thinkers in this country
the anti-federalists the Jeffersonians
the small are Republicans that have been
celebrated by people like the political
philosopher Michael Sandel these are
people for whom Europe represented
everything that was corrupt and decadent
and you're Europe's problem was
essentially that European countries
aspired in their own way to be great
powers to be great powers supported by
monarchies supported by state churches
we would rebel against all of that and
against European great power politics we
would assert the purity of American
intentions the fact that America was an
exception from the rest of the history
of the rest of the world that was true
for Europe would not necessarily be true
for us and this ideal of American
goodness has also resonated throughout
our history and throughout our culture
and it's in fact I think been the
dominant trend in other words other
things being equal we're likely to move
in the direction of goodness which fits
our understanding of ourselves much
better than the idea of greatness
so greatness in that sense has been much
more the exception rather than the rule
I try to show that
this division between goodness and
greatness is been so fundamental to our
history that in many ways it Criss
crosses it overlaps it doesn't
correspond with the usual ways we think
about the political divisions in our
country for example we use terms like
liberals and conservatives or
Republicans and Democrats goodness and
greatness don't really fit those
categories for about the first hundred
or so years of our history advocates of
American greatness have I'd as I've
defined it were almost invariably
conservatives and pretty much fairly
conservative conservatives people like
Alexander Hamilton for example hardly a
populist hardly a spokesman for popular
democratic majorities an elitist
European oriented constantly looking at
Great Britain as the proper model for
the United States wildly out of touch
with the kind of culture of goodness in
the United States but someone who had a
cosmopolitan and a worldly vision of
what greatness would mean even more
importantly an even more conservative
than Alexander Hamilton was the third
Chief Justice of the United States John
Marshall who did more than anyone in
American political history to create the
idea of a strong nation everything
Marshall did was organized around the
principle of creating a strong nation
state of overcoming the sectionalism of
his own State Virginia centralizing
power wildly interpreting the
Constitution you know I always get a
kick out of the fact that conservatives
today talk about how they believe in the
original meaning of the Constitution and
then also believe that Marshall was a
great jurist you can't believe in both
Marshall just twisted the Constitution
out of any recognizable connection
between the words on the document and
what he actually achieved but he knew
that he had to do that because he had to
overcome the resistance to national
authority that has been so central
throughout American history Abraham
Lincoln the first Republican president
and are clearly embodied and took
actions some of which violated some of
our most fundamental beliefs in
of liberties in order to preserve the
union and in order to preserve the
principle of equality that the Union
embodied Theodore Roosevelt not nearly
as conservative but certainly a
Republican and certainly the model of
Republican presidents in the early 20th
century all of them standing on the
greatness on the greatness side whereas
many of the people who stood on the
goodness side throughout the first
hundred years of our existence where to
some degree on the right to some degree
on the left in my categorization I went
include in the goodness category people
like john c calhoun the defender of
slavery who believed in her not slavery
as the good society the virtuous society
a virtuous society was in his view
absolutely not incompatible with a slave
owning society so a defender of slavery
but also one of our greatest critics of
slavery henry david thoreau of my state
of massachusetts a man who embodied the
idea that we should be a virtuous
society a good society that he we should
reject realpolitik and reject the
european worship of power in favor of a
kind of anarchy that would have now
enable the purity of the human heart to
range so that the goodness train has all
kinds of people associated with it but
it's very very clear to me that the
greatness train was predominantly a
conservative reaction up until the
beginning of the 20th century but
throughout almost all of the 20th
century there was a clear shift in which
all the advocates for American greatness
in the twentieth century were liberals
and Democrats and the Republican Party
became the party of small scale ambition
and of states rights and of reaction
against the federal government
FDR of course would be on anyone's
pantheon of great leaders for the United
States John F Kennedy whose life was too
short and we don't know what would have
happened with him but he certainly knew
the language of American greatness
Lyndon Johnson who adopted the term
Great Society to characterize his
objective I mean these were all people
who in many ways inherited the mantle of
Hamilton
and Lincoln and Marshall whereas in the
20th century the conservative movement
adopted the mantle of Jhansi Calhoun and
of the defenders of the southern way of
life and of lazy fare and of other
notions that were highly suspicious of
national authority and what national
greatness would mean so the idea of
greatness really Criss crosses the usual
way we think about liberals and
conservatives I'm not particularly
interested in when I look back at
politicians and what they tried to do
and what they try to establish I'm not
particularly interested on the positions
they took about antitrust laws or about
tariffs I see goodness and greatness as
really encompassing theories about for
example the nature of human nature or
the ideas that are meant to govern us
one of the things I try to show in my
book is that the advocates for the verge
of the vision I'm calling the good
America or almost to a person convinced
of the inherent sinfulness of human
nature that human beings were tainted by
sin that little good could be expected
of them that's why you needed a kind of
good society to overcome the badness of
individuals that you needed checks and
balances and all kinds of protections
against the inherently grasping selfish
nature of human beings whereas people
like Hamilton like Teddy Roosevelt and
in my book one of the great heroes of
20th century political philosophy Teddy
Roosevelt's major political adviser
Herbert Crowley his book the promise of
American life were filled with
optimistic readings of human nature and
of human potential the promise of
American life the whole idea is a
positive rather than a negative one as
Alexander Hamilton said in his one of
his letters trying to persuade New
Yorkers to vote for the National
Constitution he says there comes a
certain point at which you must trust
people you must have confidence in them
and it's this idea that you have covered
that human beings are
capable of doing great things that runs
throughout the one school and the notion
that human beings cannot do great things
because they're inherently encumbered by
sin runs throughout the other one
there's also a fascinating connection to
me when I look back upon these different
ideals that the goodness people are
almost invariably what I would call
theoreticians that they develop
elaborate models of how society should
work
Jhansi Calhoun's his disposition on
government was probably the greatest
work of political philosophy ever
written by an American and it's an
elaborate constitutional mechanism
essentially designed to protect slavery
in the South but it shows at work I kind
of build their of systems a systematic
political thinker in one of his letters
to a friend of his john c calhoun said
that I would do anything in my power to
save the Union except to sacrifice my
principles he was a man of principle
principles come first this was not true
of Abraham Lincoln Abraham Lincoln threw
aside his principles in order to save
the Union for Lincoln saving the Union
came first principle came second for
Calhoun it was the other way around
almost all of the goodness people had a
system if the system might be a
constitution whose original intent we
are bound by it might be lazy fair a
kind of theory a systematic theory about
how the economy is supposed to operate
that tells us what we can and can't do
for example when FDR first came into
office he was not particularly radical
in his economic policy and he said you
know he thought well let's try to spend
some money and maybe we could spend our
way out of the depression and all the
economists came up to him said you well
you can't do that because the laws of
lays I Fair won't let you do that and he
said well I'm going to do it he wasn't
guided by a principle by a theory of how
the world work he was much more guided
by experience the philosophers who had
the greatest impact upon the greatness
school of thought or were American
pragmatists and American pragmatist made
the idea
operating from experience rather than
operating from theory central to the way
they understood the world as Oliver
Wendell Holmes went wrote one of the
most famous sentences where he said the
life of the law is not logic but
experience it's not principle that you
look for but experience you want to
devise a system to account for actual
practical experiences in the real world
where either than to design a system
based upon theoretical abstraction so
these differences run throughout the
goodness and the greatness school as
well and and I find them quite striking
most of you who probably not as
interested in American history as I am I
hope I'm wrong I the more I learn about
people like Calhoun and a thorough and
so on the more fascinated I become
Abraham Lincoln himself is you know one
of those people that after a certain
point you can't get enough of you start
reading everything he ever wrote and
everything about his life because he's
such a fascinating character but we're
here in Washington and so I assume
there's more interest in the room and
our current political life than in the
history so I should talk at least a
little bit about that well this book is
in some ways a conversation with a group
of Washington based writers I've called
the neoconservatives who were I give
them credit the first people to really
begin a contemporary conversation about
greatness and what it meant the notion
of national greatness in its current
face got its start from people like
David Brooks the New York Times
columnist William Kristol of an advisor
to former adviser to Dan Quayle is how I
like to always identify Bill Kristol but
the Rasputin's of the Republican Party
is probably a more a contemporary
application
Christel Richard Perle David from these
were the people that really began this
conversation a few years back they began
it in roughly nineteen ninety eight
ninety
9 when they thought that the Republican
Party should aspire to the ideas of
greatness which in their view liberals
had abandoned because liberals have been
so scarred by the Vietnam experience so
frightened by political power that they
didn't want to have anything to do with
greatness anymore and all of these
people that I've just mentioned became
avid supporters of John McCain when
McCain as we know did lose to Bush and
interesting questions for my
neoconservative friends what would they
do and it's pretty obvious what they did
they jumped on bush's bandwagon hoping
hoping that bush would embody the same
principles themselves I think they were
wrong and thoroughly persuaded that they
were wrong to be sure we've been told by
that sterling product of American
journalism named Elizabeth boo miller
who writes these puff pieces about the
president each week and every Monday and
the new york times about what he puts on
his iPod and such other matter weighty
matters of state but we were told that
Bush keeps copies of Teddy Roosevelt's
speeches on next to his bed in Crawford
Texas and we certainly know that the
president likes to evoke the spirit of
Teddy Roosevelt but whether or not Bush
belongs and the camp of goodness or
greatness for me is a relatively easy
call he is well among other things
absolute worst president in the history
of the United States but besides that
which is after all just a matter of fact
rather than opinion mr. Bush and
certainly his party is a party that is
understood what national greatness would
require and decided to repudiate it at
almost all levels now I say that knowing
that to some degree this is not
certainly a president that is afraid of
exercising American power military power
abroad he's certainly done that and you
know it
could conceivably turn out that some
good will come of that I certainly hope
so
I am NOT one of those liberals that
wants a civil war in Iraq just to prove
that my criticism of Bush's invasion of
Iraq was wrong if the Iraqis develop a
democracy and it is the result of Bush's
foreign policy I will give him credit as
publicly as I can I don't think it's
going to happen but I do wish it did
happen and I wish it will happen because
the people of Iraq deserve the best and
there's absolutely no reason to wish
upon them the Civil War that I still
think is probably looming out there in
part because when we did what we did in
Iraq there are no doubt people in the
room and there are no doubt lots of
people in America who were opposed to
our involvement in that country my
position is that once we decided to get
involved we should have done it in the
right way and that meant a far greater
commitment of resources a far greater
commitment of troops then we did to try
to do it on the cheap
it seems to me was the big mistake of
what we did we either should not have
done it at all or we should have done it
in a way that would have made it it
success much more likely doing it on the
cheap was the mistake and why did we do
it on the cheap we did it because
however strongly the president felt
about invading Iraq there was no doubt
whatsoever that he felt more strongly
about cutting taxes but cutting taxes
has been the one thing that is never
wavered in the course of this remarkably
flip-flopping man he has never way he's
wavered every day why we should cut
taxes if there's a recession it's
because we should stimulate it if we
stimulate the economy it's because we
should slow he always has a different
reason for it but the rock-bottom
underlying reasons for cutting taxes
never changes and you cannot cut taxes
which means cutting government and stand
for a great America there's just
absolutely the equation is as sharp as
can be American greatness does require
an active government and it requires
even more a willingness on the part of
Americans to assume their obligations in
the chores that make us great greatness
is not something that can just be
imposed on people to have
to actively participate in the process
and that means through some collective
understanding of our mutual obligations
that we have toward each other as
Americans and there's only one way that
mutual obligations toward each other as
Americans comes about and that's because
we pay taxes so that the more
unfortunate among us can receive the
benefit of our beneficence so that no
one will be left behind so that we
strengthen America by strengthening
Americans it's the most fundamental
principle of all and if you're not in
favor of that it strikes me you are not
in favor of a Great America I'm
sometimes asked and I certainly wonder a
lot now that the tax cut well it's not
it's not been made permanent but it's
certainly passed why the president
decided after the 2004 election which
could be interpreted in a number of ways
why he decided to make Social Security
his number one topic it doesn't seem
like the smartest thing to have done he
isn't getting anywhere on it the 60-day
tour that was supposed to produce a
massive upswing of support for the
president seems to have increased his
unpopularity to record high levels of
social security actually it's really
quite remarkable Americans are not among
the they're not let's put it this way
avid consumers of political knowledge
they're not newspaper junkies but
everyone in America seems to know what
social security is about I mean the Bush
administration was completely convinced
that if you went to places like Florida
and North Carolina and you address that
literally people and said your money
won't be touched that they would all say
great and that never happened people
said I know how my money won't be
touched but I feel that I have an
obligation to younger people and this
just it's come from totally escaped the
president now you know it looks like
Social Security's going to be a loser
for the president and in fact it could
be a huge loser it could play the role
in his administration that Bill
Clinton's efforts to create a national
health insurance system played for his
the president could conceivably not
recover from it why therefore did he do
it this is not a dumb man I don't like
them
presidents but he's one of the great
politicians of our time a very very
successful politician who knows what he
wants and manages to get it most of the
time why did he go after Social Security
when it seems like such a loser and I
can only come up with one explanation
and that is that Bush knows as I know
that Social Security is one of the
greatest things the United States ever
did that they established the principle
of us all being obligated to one another
which is the fundamental rock-bottom
principle of a great and decent Society
and he knows that if his vision of
America is ever to be realized
Social Security in its present form
cannot be allowed to exist because the
idea that we are obligated to each other
cannot be allowed to persist and that's
why he's attacking it and that's why
he's going after it he has an idea of
what America should be and it's an idea
that resonates with all those thinkers
in American history who've made goodness
rather than greatness their essential
objective that we should get rid of a
strong national government that we
should reconsider the New Deal and
everything that the New Deal stood for
and we should even reconsider the whole
idea of national citizenship in a 1991
US Supreme Court decision involving term
limits Justice Clarence Thomas wrote
that we are not a nation but a
collection of states as if the Civil War
had never been fought as if Abraham
Lincoln had never been killed as if John
C Calhoun were still alive I mean it's
amazing all those all the blood that was
shed to create a nation in this country
and a Supreme Court judge at this day
and age can bring the nation into
existence but as you know if you read
Jeffrey Rosen's piece in The New York
Times magazine last Sunday about the new
conservative jurisprudence in the United
States Clarence Thomas belongs to a
group of legal scholars and legal
experts whose fundamental premise is
that we are not a nation and that we
shouldn't be a nation the Jeffrey Rosen
piece has a picture of Michael greif of
the American Enterprise Institute who's
one of the leading figures in my book
Michael grieve who calls himself a
member of the Federalist Society
but is actually an anti federalists
actually someone who identifies with all
of those people who were against the
creation of a federal government and
grief has absolutely no hesitation about
explaining why and why is because we
should develop a kind of pure market
system in which business runs everything
and the strong national government is
antithetical to that it is difficult to
repudiate the 14th 15th and 16th
amendments to the Constitution's without
passing new constitutional amendments
but the Supreme Court could decide if it
has the right members that the two
greatest innovations of the 20th century
the constitutional litigation which
established the principle that the New
Deal was legal and the notion that the
14th amendment incorporates fundamental
and nationalizes fundamental rights so
that they're held not just against the
states but our national rights as well
that both of those principles could be
abolished under a Supreme Court that
wanted to transform America from a great
country to what it imagines is a good
one but in my view would be quite a bad
one I think that on this present
political circumstances it is essential
for liberals and Democrats to challenge
this way of thinking but to challenge it
on the principles that have made
liberalism strong throughout the 20th
century and that is to develop an
aggressive optimistic confident
understanding of what greatness would
mean it would be difficult because there
has been a turn among liberals away from
the greatness of their own tradition we
look back upon you know this would
Kennedy and his space exploration we
look back upon certainly the war in
Vietnam in the 1960s and we say that we
overextended we reach too far there's a
sense of resignation on the part of many
on the Left Isle straited in my book
with a brief example where I I take one
of the great liberal thinkers who stood
for the principle of greatness
in the 1950s a man is still alive named
James McGregor Burns
who wrote a book called the deadlock of
democracy in which he said that the
trouble in the United States was that we
had when he called the Madisonian
political system in which there wasn't
enough political power and I compared
that with a book written by the man that
Bill Clinton named as assistant attorney
general although she was never confirmed
Lani Guinier who wrote about the exact
same subject and said we had a
manatorian
system of checks and balances only she
thought it was good and he thought it
was bad her book was called the tyranny
of the majority
it was filled with references to john c
calhoun and to protection of minority
rights it seems to me that liberals and
Democrats have to speak for majorities
they have to speak for the majority of
the American people they have to put
aside the notions that fracture us in
two different sub communities the
national greatness means that we are a
great country it doesn't mean that we're
a collection of special interests a
collection of special ethnic groups
collection of special racial categories
we are Americans first and foremost and
I think that liberals and Democrats need
to adopt that kind of language there's a
great deal of talk in the wake of 2004
about whether or not liberals and
Democrats should address moral values
which usually means religious values and
I certainly think that they should I
think that the notion that one political
party has been blessed by God and the
other cursed by the devil is so
antithetical to our democracy that it
cannot survive but I also don't think
the Democrats should just confine
themselves to religious values they
shouldn't be afraid to use them but they
shouldn't just confine themselves there
are great values in our country's
tradition they're the values of the
Enlightenment that were brought to our
shores by our founding fathers
they are fundamental values about human
dignity and human rights and human
equality they were for the best part of
our history incorporated into our ideals
they are not incorporated into our
ideals at the present time we've lost
that kind of language and I think it's
incumbent upon liberals and Democrats to
find it again so I end on somewhat
optimistic note and I conclude the book
by saying that there is a tremendous
amount of resources and a tremendous
amount of material in this country for
the right political party to go back and
develop an idea that would be inspiring
that would use the events of September
11th not to divide us but to remind us
of the great country that we've been it
happens to be the case that in the
previous crisis we've had we the people
that were in power were not great
leaders when those crises happened
Abraham Lincoln was a man who had only
been elected to Congress once he had
only been elected president with 40% of
the vote he was not considered a serious
politician the civil war happened he
actually responded quite badly at first
but he grew and he developed and he
saved the Union when the Great
Depression happened Franklin Delano
Roosevelt was generally viewed as a
gentlemanly Playboy not a serious person
incapable of responding to the crisis
and he grew and he developed and he
transformed the country when September
11th 2001 happened George Bush his first
reactions were in the same spirit he
brought us together he United us he was
inspiring I supported him he then
decided that saving his ideology saving
his party was more important than
uniting the country I think it's one of
the great scandals of American history I
can't tell you how sad I am there's this
opportunity this opportunity that grew
out of this tragedy this chance for
Americans to bring themselves together
and to unify themselves around their
inspiring ideals was instead turned into
a debate about stem cells or a debate
about gay marriage it belittles us as a
people that those are the things that
our newspapers spend their time to I
think we need to get the spirit of
greatness back and in my book I try to
do my best my care the best I can to do
it thank you very much
[Applause]
fairly quickly it would be appreciated
okay I really enjoyed your talk I'm I'm
wondering about the kind of geopolitical
implications of what it is you're saying
because greatness and goodness are
confused a when America goes abroad and
forms its foreign policy both of them
seemed to be kind of grounded in a sense
and your talk seems to be grounded in a
sense of American exceptionalism that
America actually is more than simply an
ordinary country that America actually
has got ideals which represent universal
values America is a homeland of freedom
but there is surely another and that
then gives rise to a unilateral impulse
within American foreign policy is it not
better to have a conception of America
as an ordinary power and therefore not a
virtuous nation necessarily and
therefore that being the basis of a
multilateral foreign policy listening to
others I don't I don't think we should
consider ourselves a virtuous country I
think we're a great country by the world
has made us a great country I mean we're
a great country by default that can't be
ignored we have the power we that no
other country has so it's not a question
of whether we should be great we are if
we acted with the kind of confidence I
talked about we wouldn't be afraid of
having allies and so I respect what you
said about multilateralism but a great
country welcomes allies and that's how I
would do it you briefly alluded to Bill
Clinton if former President Clinton was
in office today do you think his
greatness would carry us beyond the
don't-ask don't-tell
Bill Clinton's presidency is was a
disappointment to me and I say so in the
book I I think especially in contrast to
his successor who's you
and policies obviously don't like but
the one thing I would say about george w
bush's he understands that he's
president clinton never seems understand
that clinton sort of you know what's
going on it was like you know when
Wesley Clark came up to Bill Clinton and
said we've got the situation in Bosnia
and it's terrible
Clinton reacted by saying somebody
should do something about that I mean I
advised Bill Clinton and I work with
Bill Clinton like so many people I
admire the man personally enormous Lee
he was never up to the job I'm afraid
and it was a big disappointment I'm in
the process of applying for the job with
for the to be the Washington
correspondent for salon comms and in my
very brief cover letter
I made the observation that you're not
going to be able to explain what's going
to happen in Washington in the next 18
months or two years without explicitly
understanding the dynamics of the
Religious Right and you you almost got
to them but not quite explicitly and to
be to be very specific I call your
attention to Dana Millbank column from
April 9th about the conference that was
held in Washington and the sentiments
expressed by any number of prominent not
not fringe leaders of the right about
the American judiciary a separation of
power and some fairly outrageous things
so it like you to comment on on that
where it seems the visions of goodness
and greatness are terribly terribly
different than both perspective well the
Christian Right plays a big role in the
book you're right I did talk about them
and let's talk tonight but the notion of
America's have chosen people especially
blessed nation has its resonance today
in in the Christian Right it it that's
Tom DeLay is in many ways a unique
figure but in many ways he's in
continuity with politicians from his
part of the world that have spoken like
him and fought like him for a long time
in the past they didn't really didn't
become Majority Leader of the US House
now they do that's the difference the
last question and your answer to it kind
of links to to my question which has to
do again with the religious right there
is another book that sort of overlaps
dr. will
I think with yours Jim Wallace's book
God's politics but I'm not here to talk
about that my question is it really torn
from the headlines this coming Sunday
April 24th the Senate Majority Leader
frist is gathering with some folks in
Louisville Kentucky from the far
religious right they're running a teller
telecast and in the promotion for their
telecast and the focus is the filibuster
on judicial nominees many people here
may have read about this in the last
week the flyer for the telecast says
that basically Democrats are enemies of
people of faith my question for you is
to ask you to comment specifically on
whether you think that the fact that the
Senate majority leader
frist who plans to run for president
apparently as the candidate of the
far-right the fact that he would stoop
to what some would call this scurrilous
action of tarring democrats as being
irreligious the Washington Post
editorialized and called this beyond the
pale I'd like to ask for your comments I
actually think this might be an
important turning point I think that the
first and delay and others are wildly
overreaching and I think that there's
going to be a strong reaction against it
we saw the first signs of this in the
Terri Schiavo business where they they
got it completely wrong everything they
thought about America turned out not to
be the case I you know as I said I mean
I these are people that represent
southern states where the Republican
Party which was once almost non-existent
in the south is now pretty much becoming
a one-party system in the south the
South has never been a great friend of
national greatness the south has always
stood for a kind of patriotism and a
kind of American nationalism but in our
history the South roots 100 I mean it's
it's it's its defense of slavery
prevented the South from ever joining
the principle of national greatness a
great country could not have slavery and
the South chose to defend slavery after
the Civil War they chose to defend
racial segregation
dividing Americans you know scurrilous
stuff for a long time the South South
was democratic now it's Republican the
Republicans have inherited that legacy
part of what's going on in this country
is that people are moving to the south
and ever greater numbers giving the
South disproportionate influence the
South has also been disproportionately
influential because of the federal
structure we have that gives the
southern states extra Representatives
and so on this is not the majority I
believe of the American people the
majority of the American people
understand full well that this is a
country committed to religious tolerance
and religious pluralism and the more
this kind of ultra ultra sectarian both
sectarian and religious terms and
sectarian and political terms the more
it's exposed the more I think it will
fail if it doesn't I don't recognize my
country anymore
Norman Wow I'm gonna ask the question
that I'm not I'm such was the effect of
your presentation of your book that I
have to say I'm not sure about it you've
reduced me to the status of an uncertain
suppose your categories are quite right
and looking back the echo a considerable
tradition of historiography also lies a
Akoni both moral man an immoral society
in his depiction of the United States
and in the ironies of American history
but suppose the present situation
represents a radical discontinuity with
the continuities you've developed and
suppose we have pseudo greatness and
pseudo goodness as fabricated political
themes or ideologies you mentioned the
neoconservatives with their enormous
penchant for sending other people's sons
into battle and the reason for the
absence of full mobilization for either
Iraq and other adventures is very clear
the introduction of a draft or something
or
would introduce a debate precisely like
the Vietnam debate and might indeed
reopen American politics that's what
these people are trying to which is some
degree to avoid but it does seem to me
that the notion which has Tibetan which
I'm very unsure of of pseudo pseudo
greatness is the theme and pseudo
goodness greatest nation on earth why do
they hate us all these common things
seem to intrude in modern politics in
ways that they didn't let's say in in
the 19th century I'm not sure of that
but it sounds right to me I like it and
I run a copyright that I said pseudo
greatness and pseudo goodness real I
mean there is a pseudo element to it
that I think you're absolutely right to
identify it's almost farcical in some
ways in the way it's put forward
you know III saw that in this 2004
election I couldn't believe the way it
was being treated I mean not that you
know I don't I mean I voted for John
Kerry I actually think he ran a pretty
good campaign but here you had a man you
know who did serve his country Mahan who
did was an honorable man and
demonstrated I think great courage and
and and then you had a scoundrel running
against them and people chose the
scoundrel it does make you think that
the pseudo-element is really the
dominant one thanks for the question and
the comment I mean I'm in sympathy with
the overall argument Allen but some of
the examples raised a few questions
about the distinction between greatness
and goodness I can I I like the
distinction if it's taken as a critique
of self-righteousness
but Abraham Lincoln was good mm-hmm
Franklin Roosevelt was good they thought
they were good they they thought that
there were moral and ethical values that
they were defending and that you
discussed regarding obligations to
others for example so why the
distinction and isn't it important for
liberals to make the case publicly that
that this tradition
Calhoun delay whatever is not good they
claim they're good but that's a kind of
self-righteousness with which we're very
familiar we're good well
I I solve your problem by saying that
goodness is bad that you know this whole
tradition of goodness I think is God
knows I mean cynicism is important then
it's an end and it's an it's a it's a
break on fanaticism but no I think
categories
I think I'll defend my categories III
think that Lincoln was aware of the
dangers of what I'm calling the goodness
perspective the person who asked the
question before you Norman Birnbaum
mentioned Reinhold Niebuhr and nibor is
a huge influence in this book and Norman
perceived it correctly I and it was the
you know this the sin of pride that I
think runs throughout so much of this
kind of distinction and Lincoln to me
was a man who understood the fundamental
role of humility which made him in a
sense be able to speak for for greatness
as as I'm talking about the one person
that I'm most fascinated by in American
history is in my view the president who
really did try to be good and great
simultaneously and that's what your
Wilson someone who was both a kind of
serious Presbyterian religious thinker
filled with the language of virtue and
American innocence and yet also
responding to the great powers and the
Great War and I'm not saying that it was
the conflict between goodness and
greatness that tore Wilson apart he had
all kinds of other problems to deal with
but I think he really embodies how
difficult it is to be both at the same
time hey I'm really sympathetic to the
idea of national greatness but it seems
to me that sometimes a lot of the things
that get wrapped into it such as
mandatory national service and civics
education and things like that have a
kind of coercive element to them and I
wonder how you mitigate against that if
you're trying to show the populace how
to how to be virtuous and believe in
greatness it's a good question I'm not
sure you should I mean I think they do
have a coercive element to them coercion
is probably another word for obligation
I mean I think we have to recognize and
understand that we have certain kinds of
obligations I mean in a certain sense
Social Security is coercive that's one
of the arguments that its opponents make
about it why can't it just be voluntary
well it can't be voluntary it has to be
coercive and that's
and I think the same would be true of
some other things now you know in the
actual detail how do you work out some
kind of program of national service and
so on I'm sure the one can find ways
that the coercive elements could be
softened then there could be elements of
choice built in but you know III think
we need to in a sense be grown up and
recognize that the government does have
a coercive side and that sometimes that
you know is necessary for for democracy
and that they you know this and I say
that you know with some difficulty
because it's not the most pleasant of
thoughts but we in the United States are
so strongly committed to the idea of
individual freedom and that we should be
free to do whatever we want and so on
that I do think we need some kind of
corrective how coercive it should be
whether it should be accompanied by jail
sentences you know all those are open to
discussion but I do think recognizing
the course of element is essential hi
thanks very much I have three things
that I think somehow belong together and
and the first one goes back to your very
first questioner who asked about
greatness and and and and and
multilateralism and the idea that this
caught this idea which i think everybody
here gets can actually be very confusing
to people and and people can can
misconstrue that you're talking about a
greatness the way in which I think that
George Bush actually means it so I think
that there's a problem a possible
problem of confusion my second point
goes back to David Brooks's bed piece
from a couple of weeks ago when he said
that the Democrats don't have any great
ideas and the reason why the Republican
Party is so healthy is because the
conservatives behind it are so dynamic
and I feel and and I actually think he's
half right I think that that the
Democrats are do have this problem of
not of not being able to have a whole
lot of great ideas and actually that you
were referring to that quite nicely in
the last few minutes of your talk and
the third thing is several months ago I
said to somebody I think that the
problem with us liberals is that we have
the harder
point to make that nuance and and
America just do not belong the same
sentence and therefore when you know
when you are left with the more
complicated explanation you've lost so I
guess what I'm saying is that is it's a
problem that we haven't learned how to
talk yet that in fact we're doomed
because our argument is too complex or
we need more of you the public
intellectual who can really put this all
together for us thank you thank you i I
actually really really wish I could
answer your question and it's not for
lack of thinking about I thought about a
lot because I agree you know when Kerry
says things like well the world is
complex and you need nuance I happen to
be true the world is complex and you
need nuance but it's a it's a political
loser and you know I and what does one
do I mean I'm not a politician and I'm
not a political adviser so I'm probably
the wrong person to ask about this but
it does seem to me that we will need
some kind
I mean Teddy Roosevelt would always talk
about the presidency as a bully pulpit
as a kind of president as an educator a
tutor and so on I think there will
always be a lot of resistance to the
kind of the complications of the world
and you know that requires certain kinds
of pre political tasks almost even
before you run for office is it the case
that you know the Democrats sort of one
after another just happened to nominate
people that are losers I don't think
that's true I think you know the
Democrats have nominated some pretty
good people for office they haven't done
that badly you know I mean Gord did get
more of the popular vote than Bush and
Kerry surprised people given the time
when the country was at war you know
that he did pretty well there's no
evidence whatsoever out there that when
the president reduces things to the
simplest possible slogans which are pure
demagoguery that people actually respond
his popularity is plummeting so you know
there may be more hope
then I sent them you know this notion
that Karl Rove is a political genius and
that the Republicans have really figured
out how to frame issues in order to win
huge national mandate simply isn't true
the Republicans won two presidential
elections recently one they didn't win
the popular vote the other they barely
slipped by in the state of Ohio now
they're in a lot of trouble Karl Rove
was no political genius and I sense that
for all the success that the Republicans
have by making things simple and
attacking and negative politics I also
sense a tremendous hunger in the United
States for of the kind of leadership
that you know people know the world is
complicated they're waiting for it to be
heard and they're waiting for someone to
persuade them I'm going to have to work
at this distinction between goodness and
greatness and I'll begin by reading your
book but thank you it we're talking
against the background of the USA Today
and I grew up in the south at a time
when white supremacy trumped all other
policies and issues any other issue
raised had to yield to white supremacy I
think I'm living in a time now and when
America military supremacy Trump's all
other issues by military I mean not just
the Army in the Navy but the whole
intelligence security apparatus I think
I'm living in an America where that
nightmare which we talked about some 30
or 40 years ago when I was a graduate
student the garrison State is something
of a reality the United States bears a
lot of resemblance to an enormous arm
camp spreading its tentacles around the
world I I just wonder if you think your
distinction about what greatness amounts
to includes this thank you thank you I
don't share your sentiment I have to say
I
I see a military military power being
used in the wrong way I don't see it a
question of becoming a garrison state
again I think we have had strong
traditions of resisting that kind of
outcome and I think we once again need
to give the American people more credit
then we sometimes give them I mean we
were attacked on September 11th and
people were shocked by that they
naturally I think turned to political
leadership to protect them the president
offered them the simplest the president
offered them the simplest way to do it
to get back to the previous question I
think presidents way of doing it is to
simple that but we do need to take the
fact we need to take seriously that we
have enemies and that there are people
out there that want to kill Americans
for me it means both having the kind of
proper military response but also having
a lot of other kind of responses as well
you know but all I can say is it
compared to certain points in our past
when Americans would go into historical
fits of nationalism and resentment of
outsiders the McCarthy period for
example being the most prominent example
despite that horrible attack on
September 11th you did not see in this
country a huge outburst of support for
militarism a huge outburst of racism
against Islam I mean you saw some of
those things but I also think you saw an
American people that was primarily
afraid and primarily looking for
political leadership I don't think
they've gotten the political leadership
that will really protect them and and I
hope they'll recognize that at some
point thank you for your question thank
you dr. wolf um I agree with so much of
what you're saying but there's there's a
there's a problem there's two problems I
have with what you're saying and the
fact that I agree with it is demography
and demographics you're from Boston I
live in DC and I think there's a lot of
people here and where you're from
that would agree with an awful lot of
what you're
saying and I like these ideas that
you're bringing up about greatness and I
think that if the Democratic Party is
going to rule again we're going to have
to go back to these ideas that you bring
that you bring up but and while I agree
with these negative comments that you've
made about various political leaders
today these are political leaders today
and while you and I and a lot of people
in this room and a lot of people in the
Northeast and a lot of people in the
blue states will be an agreement in
agreeing with the statements do you make
about them we're the are are the the
person that a lot of us voted for for
president is not there the the argument
can be made that Tom DeLay still runs
the United States House of
Representatives we got a Republican
running this Senate so we've got we're
we're in this minority there however
slight we're still in the minority and
you bring up the you brought up earlier
to a earlier question about the south
and where it's going if you look at
where the the voting numbers are going
in this country they're going from blue
states to red states you said you still
have some optimism I mean and you don't
and you and if the country continues to
go this way you're not going to
recognize it I agree with you in that
but the problem I have is I think the
country is tending to go that way when I
start looking at the numbers and the
demographics of the electoral college
going more towards the red states in the
south and the rural West well my problem
may be that in my book I focused more on
the past and in the future and when you
look at the past there's a lot you can
look at and feel a sense of pride about
in this country and in some of this
country's accomplishments and having
done that I'm not prepared yet to say
that the issue has been decided as I
said to the earlier question you know I
think that the notion that our political
leaders are going to appeal to
theocratic elements in the population
and overturn the established principles
of judicial review this is not going to
happen this country's democratic
is just too rich for that to happen the
comment about I wouldn't recognize my
country if it did happen was meant to
suggest that it's not going to happen
but it's also literally true if this
country does abolish an independent
judiciary and if if all of our political
institutions are controlled entirely by
one political party so the other
political party gets no say in them
whatsoever then I won't recognize my
country it will be a very very different
country so I meant that quite literally
but I also meant it that I just don't
think it's going to happen I have too
much faith in the American experience I
also take a certain amount of comfort in
the fact as I said in the talk tonight
and as I say in the book that the
greatness tradition has always been the
minority tradition other things being
equal we don't do it and this is one of
those periods we've had periods like
this before we had the Hoover Harding
Coolidge period we had the period of
democratic presidents before Abraham
Lincoln's election Buchanan and Zachary
Scott and so I mean there have been
terrible periods in our history where
we've ignored our problems and our
difference is really divided but we've
we've come about and and we survived
them and you know this is I'm not a
politician this is a hope that that this
country with the right kind of
leadership has the resources to do it
again thank you very much thank you
thank you all for coming tonight
thanks everybody dr. Wolfe will be here
to sign books and talk to you further
thank you all for coming thank you for a
really inspiring talk
Ellen wolf is a political science
professor at Boston College return to
greatness how America lost its sense of
purpose and what it needs to do to
recover it is published by Princeton
University Press